[MUSIC PLAYING]
Rio au Vivo is a tool for
decision making regarding
sports, tourism, and nights.
We install cameras in the
favorite spots of the city,
and we broadcast them
through our website and app.
And by the palm of their
hands, all Cariocas
can have a glimpse
of what is going
on in the best
spots of the city.
I started out back on
Hermosa Beach in Los Angeles
when I lived there.
Every time before
going out, I just
checked this camera, which
was installed in a restaurant
by the sea.
And I came back to
Rio with the idea
to make something
bigger out of that.
Rio is the center of the
attention of the world
right now, to the World Cup
and also to the Olympics.
We started out just
installing cameras.
And these cameras was for
surfing, was for night outs,
and was also for tourist places.
But one advice,
repeat piece of advice
that we got from the mentors, is
to start focusing on one niche,
and when you're already
established on this one
to go to the other
one, and so on.
In the beginning,
only one person
could see the video at one time.
But as we went
along, we found out
solutions that allowed
us to have a better
quality of our services
and have a faster
initialization of the video.
There was a lot of, let's say,
barriers for us to get here.
An image is worth 1,000 words.
And today we deliver 30 images
per second in real time.
So this is something that
we're really proud of.